Hi, it's Yannis Pappas and the Bay Ridge boys history, hiking as podcasts.
And here are some tips for those people who are worried about their family
members. If Trump or Biden wins, don't worry.
If Donald Trump wins,
you can still be a white celebrity and living in gated mansion as far away from
black people as possible while simultaneously telling us their life matters.
If Joe Biden, wince, don't worry.
We can get right back to getting involved in the middle East,
send troops back and bomb the out of innocent people.
Don't worry if Donald Trump wins,
you're still living in America where you can get meat for a dollar. Don't worry.
If Joe Biden wins,
the two for 20 menu at Applebee's is still in full effect.
You fat American circle stay away from rooftops.
So you don't cause a solar eclipse. Don't worry if Donald Trump wins,
Chelsea handler will still be here to put voting stickers on her and tell you
every single day that she loved black,
Donald Trump wins Tik TOK will still be there for anyone over 40,
who wants to scroll at night, sleeping next to their wife,
and look at 15 year old girls and white air force ones doing the ducky.
And if Joe Biden wins, don't worry.
If Joe Biden wins,
we'll all live to see the first female president and she won't be Hillary
[inaudible]. And finally,
if neither candidate wins because the election is contested,
which spawns a civil war and a dictator comes to power. Hey, well,
at least Russia and the Chinese can't meddle in our elections anymore.